This is a tutorial about how I made two
different single take continuous shot
videos using Google Flow. In one of
them, I started with a VO3 clip which I
extended using V2. So, I lost all the
sound. And this is kind of what that one
looks like. Okay, here we go. One
minute, no cuts. Walking all the way
through the train.
[Music]
And the other one is a one minute
continuous take where someone's talking
the whole time.
>> There's a poem we had to read back in
high school about taking the road less
traveled.
>> And she's kind of a consistent
character, but not really if you compare
the start frame and the end frame. I
used V3 fast mode. And in this tutorial,
I'm going to redo that movie in V3
quality, so we can kind of compare the
fast mode versus the quality mode. I
know a lot of people have questions
about that. The big difference, of
course, is the number of credits each
one uses. So, V3 quality uses 100
credits and V3 fast uses 20 credits. So,
you basically get five to one if I did
my math right. So, we're going to learn
two different ways to do continuous
shots. One is extending a clip and one
is using what's commonly known as the
last frame first frame technique and
that uses the frames to video option in
Google Flow.
>> Okay, here we go. 1 minute, no cuts.
Walking all the way through the train.
>> So, the trick with this one is that I
wanted to start with someone talking
because VO3 has audio and V2 doesn't. I
wanted to start with a VO3 clip to begin
with some dialogue and then as I
extended it, I could just add some
music. So, I like this idea of a
character walking down a train and
having the passengers change into
different types of passengers as she's
walking through it. So, this was the
clip that I started with. This was the
very first prompt I tried.
Okay, this is a one minute continuous
shot video walking through a train
>> and the wrong character is saying the
line. Like if you look at here, it
should be the production assistant
saying that line. So I tried it again
and it worked. So once I had that one, I
just followed this prompt and then just
continued to change who the passengers
were. So I'll show you what I mean. So
if you were doing this and you had just
found your first clip that you liked,
you would go add to scene. And now we're
over to scene builder. So this is the
project and then this is the scene
builder where we can arrange the scenes.
Everything we generate in scene builder
will also be in this project. What I did
is I had this initial shot and then I
clicked the plus button and went to
extend.
And now it says what should happen next?
And over here is our prompt for this
happens and then the extended shot. So
the first one I did was camera tracking
motion as the conductor walks down the
aisle revealing more passengers. And I
think this is an important part where we
say there are more passengers being
revealed and then we say the passengers
are all anthropomorphic animals and then
she smiles in amusement. So we're
getting a reaction from her. So let's
see how this one turns out. And again
I'm doing Oh, let me show you. So it
looks like I can do this in V3 fast
mode. Um let's try it. And it says no.
This feature isn't supported in V3 fast.
You have to switch to V2. So, the only
way we can extend these clips is to use
V2 fast for now. And hopefully that will
change soon. But as of right now, that's
the only one that will work for this
technique. And then a little bit later,
I'm going to show you how to extend a
clip using VO3. So, we're going to do
the anthropomorphic animals like I did
in my original. All right, let's see how
that turns out. So, you can either you
can either grab this and just kind of
scrub and see what happens. Um, or you
can play it
So now we have the anthropomorphic
animals. Let's do another one. So we'll
just click the plus button again and
click extend. What should happen next?
And we'll paste that same prompt. And
now we'll change them to um let's change
them to something different that wasn't
in my original um ballerinas. How about
And let's try and give her a little bit
of action, which I didn't really do. Um
so let's have the conductor wave to one
ballerina. All right. Let's just kind of
see what happened here.
Oh, now she stopped entirely.
What happened there? Now she waved. So,
what was that? So, I I can't remember
exact prompt that we did. So, what I can
do is go back to this project and see
camera tracking as she walks down. So,
I'm going to go back to scene builder.
There's nothing in this prompt that
makes me think it should have just
stopped and had her turn around and go
that way. It looks like it thinks that
she's standing still
um because of this that maybe this looks
like she's not moving. What we can do
here is trim it. So we can go here,
trim back,
and now we'll extend again. So we've
kind of trimmed to the end here. So now
we're starting from there instead of
where we were before. And we'll extend
from here.
I think it's important to show these
times that things don't work out because
I think if you see a tutorial and
everything works out perfectly, but they
don't always work the way they're
supposed to. And a lot of times you run
into problems and you have to figure out
ways around them. So, thanks for
sticking with me through these mistakes.
See if that helped at all.
Yeah. So, now we got her walking again.
The trick there was that the final frame
looked too much like she was just
standing there and it didn't know that
she was in motion. All right. And that
was basically what I did. So, you know,
it started with a V3 clip and then went
to the V2 and the V2 and just kept
continually doing that and changing the
background characters um to, you know,
different creatures and aliens and
things like that. So, that's how I did
that one. There was one point where I
extended and I had to leave the train. I
was trying to figure out how to get out
of the train and that took a little bit
more work. Um, let me show you that
really quick. I wanted her to come to
the end of the train and walk off the
train. Um, and I'm going to try this one
again. But here's what happened for me.
Um, she gets there and then all of a
sudden the camera started to pan up and
I thought, well, that's kind of
interesting. What if what if um at the
end of this the camera continues to pan
up um and
now we kind of see the top of the train.
It took a little bit. Didn't quite get
there. There we go. This was like, okay,
now I'm outside the train. This is
perfect. So, I liked that. And then I
was able to try different things. And
this is for me where the project went
off the rails because I was like, oh, I
could have it pan over here. So, I tried
a bunch of things. And um that's where I
really went through credits on this
project was trying to figure out what
happens after we get out of the train.
But the actual walk through the train
was pretty easy to get through. That's
how you use Google Flow to do a single
continuous shot with VO3 that extends
with V2 clips. Now, let's do one with V3
quality mode and extend them that way. I
know you're probably thinking like,
"Wait, but you said that you can't
extend them in V3." And you can't, but
you can do this other technique that
many of you know about called last
frame, first frame.
>> There's a poem we had to read back in
high school about taking the road less
traveled.
>> So, this is how she started off and then
we see her walking for one minute. And
for the most part, initially, you don't
really notice that she's changing. And
then every 8 seconds, it gets worse and
worse. And as someone in the comments
pointed out, and I was thinking as well,
it's like when you used to do VHS tapes,
every time you make a copy, every copy
is worse than the version that came
before it. So the midjourney image that
we're starting with looks fine. Then
we're doing a screen grab from an AI
generated video, which doesn't have the
same quality, doesn't have the same
amount of detail, and so it's a little
bit less quality, and then we just keep
reducing the quality. So over time it
just gets to be it looks more like this
at the end. So for starting from
scratch, we can go to text to video and
click frames to video. And for these
continuous shots, we're only going to
use a start frame because we want the
end frame to be wherever the video ends
up going. And then we'll use the last
frame of that video as the start frame
for the next video. That's why they call
it last frame, first frame. So once
we're on frames to video, we click this
plus button to upload a new one. It
remembers all of the previous ones that
you've uploaded. So since I started with
this one, I'm just going to click this
button here. Um you could also just
upload one from scratch. Um and since I
did this in VO fast last time, I'm going
to do So this is 20 credits to do frames
to video. I'm going to go to quality
mode. And now it's going to be 100
credits. Okay. So let's see how this
goes.
There's a poem we had to read back in
high school about taking the road less
traveled.
>> I think that looks really good. Um, so
let's do this. Let's add it to the
scene. So we're in the project here and
we want to get it over to scene builder.
So let's add it to scene.
And now we're in scene builder. Um, and
what I did when I did it is I just
jumped to the last frame of each of the
clips like this. And then there's a
button at the top here that says save
frame as asset. And I click that one and
then it adds the frame there. And as you
can see looking at these, you can kind
of see how she changes over time. So she
starts off here and then it's
progressively changing and now it's a
completely different person. So this is
a good way to visualize the degradation
of doing the last frame each time. Um,
one thing that I wanted to try and
someone suggested, um, was not
necessarily sometimes the last frame is
blurry. Like if you'll see around her
eyes, they're a little bit blurry where
if you go here, they're not quite as
blurry. So, because this is a little bit
higher quality here, um, we're going to
use this as the last frame. Um, and I
know what you're thinking. It's not all
going to blend together. But what I
noticed is when I did last frame, first
frame, and actually used the last frame,
I still had to trim up the clips in a
video editing program. It it wasn't a
seamless single clip. Um, I had to
download each individual clip and trim
them up. And since I have to do that
anyway, I may as well try and find the
best clip that I can. So, let's use this
frame as asset. And I don't want to go
too far back as she talks almost all the
way to the end. Let's see. less travel.
>> Yeah. So, we've got like a like a
quarter of a second or so. So, that's a
pretty good shot there, right? All
right. So, we'll use this frame as the
asset. I like this too cuz she's looking
at the camera. So, hopefully this will
help keep her consistent. So, if this
makes sense, we've got our first clip
here. We've saved this frame as an
asset. So, now we're using this last
frame or almost last frame as our first
frame over here. So, now motion tracking
shot of the woman walking. She says,
"Everyone was so sure they'd take the
road less traveled, including me." So,
we've switched over here to V3 fast
mode. I'm going to switch back to V3
quality mode. So, I'm not sure why it
switched over, but it did. And as you
can see, we're going from 20 to 100
credits again. And now, let's run this
one.
>> Everyone was so sure they'll take the
road less traveled, me included. Already
we can kind of see between that and that
it's kind of the same, but we we I can
tell we're going to we're losing it a
little bit, right? Um let's try that,
but this time let's trim it up a little
bit. So, we've trimmed it and we'll save
frame as asset
and click that and then say motion
tracking. Now, one thing that I've
noticed is like sometimes you can add
words in there like regretfully uh to
try and give her a little bit of
emotion. Sometimes it works, sometimes
it doesn't. But let's see how this
works.
>> But that's not how things turned out.
I've always taken the road most
traveled.
>> If you've ever used VO3, you know this,
and I have had a lot of people tell me
all of the things that you can do to not
get subtitles. And I've tried all of
them, and nothing works 100%. I kind of
get the impression that not putting
quotes in helps a little bit, but as you
can see in that one, there are no
quotes. And I've tried the same thing by
saying no subtitles, and I still get
subtitles. So, so if I were doing this
for real and not for this tutorial, I
would redo this one. Uh, but since
there's not captions on this final frame
that we want to use, I'm just going to
keep them for now. That's actually a
pretty good shot. I think you can kind
of tell she's walking and she's smiling
a little bit. Let's actually use the
final frame this time. Now, I did this a
little bit later in mind, but I wanted
to slowly introduce things that are
changing. Um, so we can say motion
tracking shot of the woman walking. So,
now we can introduce other elements that
will be showing up as she's walking.
>> I did all the things I was supposed to
do. Got a job, got married, got
divorced.
Rinse and repeat.
So, on the pro side, I love the fact
that we switched to this profile view
and we have this person in the park
bench like the prompt said. Um, on the
con side, the talking, if you just look
at it in general, it's fine, but when
she's talking, it seems like maybe she's
talking to the interviewer over here and
the camera moved to the side. We have a
lot to work with here because she says
rinse and repeat here. I think she got
some extra piercings, too, maybe. All
right, let's kind of play off of this
and let's have someone holding a boom
mic. Like like the camera person moved
over. I imagine there's someone holding
a boom mic over here and there's an
interviewer here and we're the camera.
>> But I like where I'm at now
and I only got here because my road took
me here.
>> And let's update the script a little
bit. I It was like 11:00 p.m. at night
when I was writing this. So, let's just
change it. I'm not going to change it
too much, but let's just have her say,
um,
>> and why wouldn't I?
This road made me younger in 60 seconds.
>> So, I think you get the idea of how to
do it. So, is V3 quality perfect? No.
But it's definitely a lot better than
the fast mode in terms of taking the
last frame and using it as the first
frame. The tradeoff there is that it's
much more credit intensive. So, it's
five to one like I said. So, you can do
a lot more iterating with the fast mode.
I hope this was helpful. I hope this
helps you uh create single continuous
shots using either of the methods,
whether you're extending a clip or
whether you're doing the last frame
first frame or maybe you're doing a
combination of both. I don't know. U but
hopefully that helps you understand how
people are doing these really cool
shots. And that's it for me. Uh do you
have any final words?
Sub subscribe to AI video school and
come along for the along for the ride.
[Applause]
[Music]